foreign
[Music]
big dogs I'm trying to get home I know
which way that is oh great
oh no that can't be right
I'm lost you're a stray man you can do
anything you want this beer doesn't
taste good but I like how it's making me
feel have you ever humped anything
before I recently [__] this couch
that's sex in my life and she dirty too
no well I I can tell looks like she
hasn't been washed in years I'll see you
later baby it was nice to meet you I
really should find my way back home we
could help
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now this could be a lot worse how could
this get worse huh how could it get
worse
hold on Buddy
oh wow your balls look huge from this
angle thank you but holy
thing I have ever seen and I'm Dennis
Quaid and Dennis Quaid has seen some
starving how many of these should we eat
all of them give me a sec whoa
whoa friend you look different too how
so is it my human hands
full kind what do we do calm down I got
this hello officer none of us up
here
good day be home by dinner I love you
Mr Fielding good morning morning
Catherine
and here are your daughters Angela and
Catherine about seven hours ago and
that's the last information we have
hey hey you found her
we and Catherine doing out there in
those woods you're just walking and
walking
Angela can you tell your dad how long
you were gone a few hours
maybe you've been gone three days
[Music]
how'd you say I didn't say nothing
I thought I heard you say something
hey baby
you okay
wherever those girls went they brought
something back with him the body and the
blood of Jesus Christ
are you in the blood
Catherine body in the blood
the body in the blood the body and the
blood countries
have you ever seen anything like this
no but there are people out there
[Music]
[Applause]
experience with possession yes more than
that like
I believe you can help get our girls
back
so citizen is a ritual culture every
religion they all use different methods
it's going to take all of them
[Music]
we've met before
[Applause]
[Music]
what did you do
is that Catherine's heartbeat they're
beating in shape
[Music]
you're all the very best in the world at
what you do
want you to know that this isn't your
typical contract
it's more like a
competition to kill me king of killers
or I can guarantee I will kill you
still on for tonight right 8 p.m at the
coal train our anniversary is tomorrow
Marcus
[Music]
I'll find out how to do this
you're invited to eliminate the world's
greatest assassin so who's the client
dracos I'm in were they sending in
welcome to Japan you set all this up I'm
your employer I work alone
he leaves until the game
and we fight hard
and Die With Honor that's what I'm
doing you set this whole thing up you
have to change the rules on it that the
only way we survive this is if we work
together all of us versus you
fun does that sound
[Applause]
I told you I was competitive
[Music]
ly
you sure you want a piece of that
who's next
foreign
the cancer is still spreading I'm afraid
there's nothing else we can do there is
one person who might be able to help our
program is a two-pronged treatment
outside Mexico City the results have
been stunning she saved my life
you're in very good hands with us
after that what happens then your whole
life actually John Kramer
according to these scans the tumor was
never removed how much time do I have
months at best
I still have a lot of work that needs to
be done
[Music]
hello everyone it's time to play a game
we all pretended to kill me the one I
have planned for each of you is very
real
you
No Light
No sound the only thing I have not
provide is your anesthetic but trust me
you will want to remain alert
[Music]
out of all the men to cheat you picked
John Crane please don't hesitate place a
big enough piece of yours or you grow
tissue into the glass enzyme tank this
will save your life
don't you
just not retribution it's a Reawakening
[Music]
little dog the choice is yours
the streets are getting covered in body
parts and we're sitting on our hands how
many dead 20. I need you Israel needs
you
with every bomb a message is sent to our
people each time to send a message of
Our Own
[Music]
I want you to find out who did this to
my daughter and I want them dead no one
has to know whether like ghosts
guys something's happening
tell me what you're doing here Avi right
outside Gaza with the U.S senator
what's going on another bomb in
Jerusalem five minutes ago the engineer
that's our Target all hands on decks
teaching them how to make bombs the
bombs may be sufficient
if it's known strategy in these attacks
we need to think like Mad Men
where is I'm sorry what was that the
engineer yeah don't scare me I'm not
trying to scare you I'm trying to
prepare you I'm already prepared to die
we'll see about that
[Music]
kids alone
this is all our fun brother
we gotta find a way into that house
you see engineer he's here
[Applause]
I need a visual before you disappear
Ed
[Music]
[Applause]
kill Denver's prodigal child of the
Milky Way
Nick Fury my favorite one-eyed man of
Entry how goes it out there I am cold No
Air
space
[Applause]
Captain Marvel the annihilator
you took everything from me
and now I'm returning the favor
what is happening to me
[Music]
she's entangled our light-based powers
so we switch places whenever we use them
you can absorb light
I can see it and Kamala who's Kamala hi
she can turn light into physical matter
which I have never heard of I could
totally show you no
[Music]
she's targeting every planet we call
home
I would never choose to bring anybody
into this
you are not the only thing standing
between this and the universe
oh my God we're a team
[Music]
further
faster
[Music]
I can't can you I got it
[Applause]
[Music]
isn't it beautiful oh maybe we should go
say hi hey there Jack talked to a girl a
girl he wants to marry her what I say
that you said it with your eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
they must be migrating migration what a
stupid idea okay you're impossible
because I found a safe place for us to
live
I want us to get out and see the world
so the father would I be if I put my
young child In Harm's Way for no reason
except a chance at a Caribbean vacation
I don't want to miss out on life because
you're afraid to leave this pond
here we go tail for the torsion check
Wing deployment
hey
why are we the only Birds heading this
way
please
I promise adventure and this is exactly
what I promised
can we
you're old enough to do it in the sky
now we have a number two situation oh
but it's gross every bird does it in the
sky
no one
no one there I told you we are not
Landing there is no way we're Landing
when Mallard do it now or we leave
without you okay okay
we are completely lost we're trying to
get to Jamaica yeah I love birds it's
this way well we are not flying through
this crazy death trap of a city just
stay close to me and everything will be
all right
I'm okay yeah no I'm okay we can do this
maybe you don't stick too close
no doubt you've seen the chaos in the
streets
we must make an example or France will
fall
what would you do if this assignment of
defense was transferred to you
[Applause]
I promise you brilliant successes
[Music]
this is my uniform
I love the French Victory too long
what is your name I'm pulling as the
course of my life just changed Napoleon
I'm destined for greatness
that I was in power will only see me as
a sword
I suggest you take the throne as a king
shall we vote
[Applause]
burning has held the world hostage with
his egotism and his lack of simple good
manners
you think you're great
that is nothing without me
all of Europe is United forces against
me what's the outcome of this if you
don't succeed
Your Majesty we are discovered good
I'm the first to admit when I make a
mistake
simply never do
[Music]
this is Craig tiddle thanks doll and
this is Trevor Brock you have a good day
my [__] is [__] massive it always
leaves the ladies sore but honey just
keeps rolling in the good times never
stop there's never been a man like me
and I always
brought my two top salesman YouTube
[__] look like y'all could be
twins
[Music]
very dissimilar
the only thing I have from the dad I
never knew is
we must be brothers that's just brothers
Trevor twins wow we're twins we're
[__] identical twins if mom and dad
got married again then we'd have a real
family what if we trick them into
getting back together
what are you doing here the twins
[Music]
so get in the line dropping your knees
and suck my [__] dick
should I open another bottle I know it's
our second but we're not Baptists should
we drown them in the bathtub in an
old-fashioned way y'all [__] up I'm
gay queer is a three dollar bill and
just as thin who like the [__] hand
job and I don't I only play to win oh
God
[Music]
wow a lady boss I guess it really is the
year that it is
sorry did you say sewer boys
[Music]
[Applause]
the joker
as you can see Metropolis has gone
positively Gotham since the Justice
League disappeared it's out of Trace but
we've been missing what do you call when
your Heroes need Heroes
now we can find out what happened to the
Justice League faster than a speeding
bullets more powerful than a locomotive
just like Superman
oh no we're sealed in all you have to do
is unmask this Phantom before all these
out of control villains destroy the
world
ah giganta
most comptonian exiles
Solomon Grundy
rats right
crypto all right all right we have to
look for Clues what's the point what's
the point of any of this why am I
trapped in here with a bunch of annoying
kids
quick
ly
super duper
thank you
who's a good boy who's a good boy come
on let's go
this guy moves take his head off do you
have any idea whose money
[Music]
we got a 904 on Old Finch Road and we
got two dead
what was that we got the money the money
we killed two people trying
two men in and out what you thinking
it's gonna be about pills and money and
Pistol
if I can understand what you stake here
she's my niece I understand what's at
stake what do you know it's a damn
Empire body you're saying this outfit is
Mom
locals that's all nothing that can't be
handled quick
I'll recover what was taken
morning Shelby
[Music]
hey look this can be worked out well
that's why I'm here
we're watching your family I got nothing
to do with this
they do now
hey Sheriff Shelby
I don't believe I know you
'll be okay
you're welcome
oh
this ain't your world
you don't control it
I didn't ask for this
[Applause]
[Music]
and they always sliding towards the edge
it's up to you how comfortable you are
doing it
[Music]
I've spent the past seven years
traveling the world perfecting my craft
you see I'm something of a magician
inventor and chocolate maker so quiet up
and listen down nope scratch that
reverse it
Mr wonkara can say you're a man a great
Ingenuity what are you doing
I'm making chocolate of course how do
you like dark white nutty absolutely
insane many people have come here to
sell chocolate they've all been crushed
by the chocolate
you can't get a shock without selling
chocolate and you can't sell chocolate
without a shop
no daydreaming what are we gonna do
Willie
huh huh
huh a double heart get the pencil paper
uh-huh I got an idea
I know things have been easy for you
they're gonna get better you promise I
think he promised left the most solemn
bow there is where do we start
where is this it's just cool what's
happening
let's find out shall we who's forever
nothing to see here just a small group
of people to find the laws of gravity
ladies and gentlemen of the gallery
Gourmet
my name is Willy Wonka
too good
yeah pretty sure I've gained about 150
pounds in the last two weeks you can
change her life as organ change all
their lives
every good thing in this world started
with a dream
so you hold on to yours
Here We Go Mama
mark my words this is gonna be the
greatest chocolate shop the world's ever
seen
so you're the funny little man who's
been following me I will have you know
that I am a perfectly respectable size
foreign
oh I don't think I want to hear that too
late I started dancing now once we've
started We Can't Stop
I love you so much
someone
killed my son I need to know it you
gotta leave but I don't think that's
what you should be thinking about right
now it loves Michael and I'm sad he's
gone I'm pregnant
I'm here to help but you need to talk to
other people in your situation you are
my best writer right you know I didn't
make him a junkie no I don't know that
is he still feeling that's the thing he
had stopped
somebody called him that night he left
all freaked out and then bow who's that
it's about fifty thousand dollars worth
of dirty heroin
I want you to talk to me on the record
you remember Mike's friend ducky we
think him and Michael might have been in
business together selling heroin coat
with fentanyl stuff called mother's milk
Mike was killed off the block from one
at ducky stash houses
back and killed Michael I know he would
not do this and who killed him
you saw what happened
you feeling okay man no
not really
you followed him he could have killed
you
[Music]
saw the person broken
don't make any sense
we got a lead a what we got a lead
helping and healing is actually what you
want you really need to see it for what
it is
don't I get to know who killed my son
[Music]
I assume you know the implications of
this
no more than anyone
it's the last chance okay
I don't know what's best
Miguel have you ever gotten into a fight
it's like what everyone does
yes it was me and that one dude we were
both looking at each other so we ended
up aggressively hugging does that count
oh my God right
hey son we have to move in a week I got
offered a new job today I don't want to
lose my friends
I need your help I want to get into a
fight what
you want me to help I got you you need
to be prepared you need strategy like
Bruce Lee the best fighters see
themselves winning so they win
foreign
I'm ready let's go I'm about to drop
this handsome [__]
oh you can't fight a kid with a broken
arm what's up my cast
what's going on with you Miguel huh
[Music]
we need to do some work on you you know
what to do close your eyes and visualize
let's pick someone else right now
the problem is you're still afraid of
getting hit so it has to be done no we
did not now you're really ready
just go over there and say to him
exactly what's written down on this
paper
Rio can you help me with the vision
brand please thank you me home
his name
Johnny Cage
his job keep up the autographing is
acting
yeah actually I'm really more into
dramas eventually the jokes to me son
but his passion though is action I just
wanna know how you got so cool the truth
is
let's pull it a lot in school you're
gonna cry little baby my mom took me to
the local dojo and my life changed
forever
write this down kick first be awesome
make money so cool
from Warner Brothers animation everyone
decent
[Music]
feel that
in a world where an evil cult threatens
Humanity look what I have
will fly
and the Heads Are Gonna Roll
did you see that yes she just jumped out
and I spin kicked her head off enough
need you for the Brotherhood this club
sounds great where do I sign [__] you
Joel McHale
wwjcp what would Johnny Cage do Jennifer
Gray you still don't get it do me I'm
starting to and Gilbert Godfrey [__]
superheroes
[Music]
sorry about that I don't mind
either do I
Mortal Kombat Legends cage match
I'm sure he's fine
see he's fine
[Music]
I am Dr nandor fodorp the world's
foremost parapsychologist I am not a
skeptic this is the strangest case I
ever ever a family living in Farmhouse
claim a talking Mongoose lives in their
Barn
his name is Jeff
I'm talking Mongoose the urban family
are peculiar Did You observe this
creature no no I did hear it we are
going to the Isle of Man I have almost
20 years of research in this field
is the creature here well because we
can't see him doesn't mean he ain't here
I see
[Music]
Dr photo has a tremendous skepticism
indeed
this is an inexplicable Force you say
the way Rascal's probably watching us
right now everybody on this island has
their Jeff story tell me yours you and I
both know Rhino Jab
[Music]
can you tell him to come out so he can
see him
is that him there
strike me as con artists
we're here with our eyes as much as we
do Aries these people are lying I think
he exists I'm certain of it just show
yourself I mean you know harm please
show me that you're real
there's a call for you
it's from him
hello
[Music]
[Applause]
surprise you are going to Taipei like
Taiwan
we want to give you something special
it's going to be the perfect summer hi
hi I'm Sophie ha like haha I never do
you go to college
um are you excited for the summer
talk
um I don't really know if excited is the
right word
you are here to learn and the experience
your heritage
parents send their kids here because
they think it's a cultural program but
we're all here because we know what it
really is
one big party
[Music]
as ever you should ask ever out you're
single and she's struggles with social
skills and making friends and stuff like
that it's perfect what catch you later
ever bye
Rick
maybe this trip is your chance to let
loose for a change live a little it was
good I didn't mean to scare you I'm
Xavier ever forever ever
where are you going oh what about curfew
hey ever remember that crazy
no exactly because no one ever remembers
those nights if I just
breathing feeling better
it's getting a lot better Chinese
working you're right
yeah um
right now in life it feels like I'm torn
between two of everything when I'm with
you I'm more me than I've ever been I
don't know what I want here's the thing
you are so much about the life that you
want you never take the time to
appreciate the life that you have
Go Let It Go
here we are it's one of my favorite
spots
this is a love letter to a place that I
never knew eight weeks ago now it's part
of me
what now forever ever if I just let go
[Music]
When The War started
they protected me
better care of me than humans sort of
they're not people Maya
it's just programming
10 years ago today the artificial
intelligence created to protect us
detonated a nuclear warhead in Los
Angeles
this is a fight for our very existence
we are this close to winning the war
with the AI are developing a super
weapon
retrieve it
they went
[Music]
did you locate the weapon yeah it's just
a kid
are you going to heaven no
you gotta be a good person to go to
heaven so we're just saying we can't go
to heaven because you're not good
and I'm not a person
you're gonna do other things she looks
like a little girl now but she's growing
Whoever has that kid wins the war
who said you want me
what do you want sweetie a robots to be
free
oh we don't have that in the fridge how
about ice cream
foreign
[Music]
[__]
do you know how to find out who this
handle belongs to you really think a
weird account is haunting your apartment
here David he was only 10 and his mother
went insane
is not my team is your son and you put
him in a coma
Dr Landers
[Music]
oh my God
you've seen my son David I'm haven't you
what does he want ask him yourself
all right
[Music]